El cuarto, estamos diseñando terapéuticos inteligentes que hagan estimaciones
y rebasen medicinas actuales,
los cuales son instrumentos imprecisos.
Por ejemplo, para dirigirse a un subconjunto de células inmunes
responsables de un desorden autoinmune,
y distinguirlas de la vasta mayoría de células inmunes saludables.
Por último, inspirados en materiales biológicos sin igual,
como seda, concha de abulón, dientes y otros,
estamos diseñando nuevos materiales de proteínas
para afrontar los desafíos en energías y ecología.
Para lograr todo esto, nuestro instituto está creciendo.
Deseamos atraer diversos científicos talentosos y llenos de energía
de todo el mundo, en cualquier etapa de su carrera,
para que se nos unan.
También pueden participar en la revolución del diseño de proteínas
a través de nuestro juego en línea de plegamiento y diseño "Foldit".
Y a través de nuestro proyecto difundido de computadora "Rosetta@home",
al cual pueden acceder desde su laptop y celular inteligente Android.
Mi trabajo es hacer del mundo un lugar mejor a través del diseño de proteínas.
Estoy tan entusiasmado de lo que podemos lograr juntos.
Espero que se nos unan,
y gracias.
(Aplausos y ovaciones)